hundreds of thousands of people marched
through London demanding a second brexit
referendum according to the organizers a
total of a million people were out on
the streets
dozens of speakers addressed the crowds
in Parliament Square including MPs
celebrities and campaigners and
meanwhile a petition calling for article
52 be revoked and for brexit to be
effectively cancer or it has reached
four point eight million signatures well
one of those who spoke to the rally
yesterday is the Green Party MP Caroline
Lucas she joins her set here now and
what was the atmosphere like yesterday
it was amazing I mean the estimates are
that there were a million people on the
streets and I think we really struck me
was that there were so many young people
lots of children people from all over
the country and they were talking about
having got up at literally two o'clock
in the morning to get there from
Scotland there were people from Northern
Ireland people actually from other
European countries UK citizens have come
back to try to make sure their voices
are heard as well so it was very
positive but also I think very worried
and I just want to have a used to make
it rally of course and I just want to
pick up on something that you said when
you address the crowd you said the
bricks that that's on offer is so
dangerous and so damaging and so deeply
flawed that it would be profoundly
undemocratic not to have a people's vote
so I understand of course that you think
the brexit deal is is dangerous that
it's flawed but why is it undemocratic
because three years ago no one had any
idea what bricks actually looked like so
we had no sense of the detail of what
were being asked to vote on and I think
there's such a gulf now between what we
were told was going to happen this deal
that was going to have the exact same
benefits where it was going to be the
easiest trade deal to do in history
where we could be still basically having
all of the benefits of being part of the
club without paying for that the reality
has turned out to be so very different
no one was talking then about
stockpiling food and medicines no one
was talking about turning the m20 into a
huge lorry park I think so much new
information has become available now
that we didn't have three years ago but
it's right for people to have that say
it's at the same time you know I spent a
lot of time the show traveling to
different parts of the country talking
to people and I have to say I'm always
really struck by just how well informed
people are and so I guess I would kind
of come back at this assumption that
people didn't know what they were voting
for many people
they did know exactly what they're
voting for they knew there was could be
an economic hit they knew that there may
be delays at Dover and yet they thought
it was worth it then and anything so now
I want to make clear that I'm not saying
that I think people were somehow stupid
or ignorant I don't think that at all
but I do think that we didn't have the
detail of the different kinds of brexit
that could be on offer and the very very
fact that you know within trees maze own
cabinet there is so much disagreement
about what brexit means I don't think we
in Parliament can presume to know what
seventeen point four million people who
voted for the eve actually do mean in
terms of which version of those bricks
it's that they know they want to do that
you well I've been traveling around the
country too and talking with them and
I've just been struck by how there are a
hundred different reasons that people
gave for leaving the EU but one thing
they did want was to have a voice to
have a say and I think there's so much
we should be doing to look at how we use
people's vote if we get it as kind of a
catalyst to look at that wide-ranging
social and economic transformation that
the country needs also constitutional
reform the sense that people outside of
London but to give you around the rest
of England feel they have no voice no
say in the decisions that get taken so I
think there were so many issues that
were bound up in that brexit vote we
need to unpack some of those citizens
assemblers might be one way of doing
that to look at the way in which the UK
needs to reform but when it comes to the
actual decision on whether or not to
leave the EU and on what terms to leave
the EU I don't think you can say that
you're undermining democracy to be
extending it in a sense going back to
the people to check that they're happy
with that decision it's a it's a
decision of such importance that will
affect us for so many generations surely
we should just make sure I was quite
struck with the interview with the
Chancellor Philip Hammond I'm not sure
if you caught it or not watching it but
he effectively didn't rule out the idea
of having a second vote on Theresa Mays
brexit deal if it passes and you of
course have been having lots of
conversations with the government you've
been in to see Theresa May I mean what's
your sense do you think a second that
referendum might actually happen I do
think it might not just wishful thinking
no I genuinely think it might because I
think it's the key that unlocks a
majority behind any of the other options
so you're right this coming week we're
talking about not just whether or not
mrs. May brings back her deal but
so-called indicative votes all of these
other options that might be on the table
I don't think any one of those is going
to get a majority unless it's linked
to the idea of having public
confirmation via a public vote so would
you vote for any of the options if it
meant having a vote afterwards would you
accept Teresa may still for example and
the other thing with with a heavy heart
I would accept resumes May's deal if it
was intrinsically linked in the very
same motion to the idea of it going back
to the people because I think that sense
of public consent public informed
consent which is what I think we didn't
have last time is so vital I mean the
big question is if there is a second
referendum what do you think should be
on the ballot paper well what I think
should be on the ballot paper are
options that are specific and
deliverable and that means remain we
know what that looks like and we do
pretty much know what mrs. Mays deal
looks like although there's lots of
unknowns but essentially that's the
strongest thing that we have so my
preference would be to have those two
things on the ballot paper in terms of
say that there should be an option to
leave no D okay we look at that and say
hang on a minute my vote isn't
represented there lots of the people who
voted leave you will already feel upset
the idea of having a friend is that a
lot about that issue of putting no deal
on the ballot paper but I just think it
would be so irresponsible for any
government to actually leave with no
deal not least because it would mean
contravening all of our international
agreements around Northern Ireland and
the Good Friday Agreement because if you
leave without a deal you end up with a
hard border in Northern Ireland there's
no getting around that is that
democratic I go back to what Democratic
well I think first of all I don't think
it's democratic to be selling Ireland
down the river I think it's massively
reckless in fact to be undermining the
Good Friday Agreement the Northern
Ireland agreement and that potential for
that hard border and secondly let's not
forget that Theresa May has had three
very strong brexit ears in that role as
brexit secretary she hasn't put in there
remain as she's put in David Davis and
then I'm tired like I remember real name
veneer a very one and now Stephen
Barclay they are people who have been
trying their best to get the the
harshest bricks that they could on and
they've ended up with the deal that's on
the table so if that is the deal that
Scots at least some with a result and
theythey will argue they didn't get what
they wanted well she's had three of them
so between them like what I'm trying to
say is they should have been able to
work out a brexit that was hard enough
for their purposes but was a deliverable
one from the EU now if in the time
available
Peter bone
someone else from the ERG can suddenly
miraculously come up with a more hard
brexit that is going to be agreed by the
EU so be it put it on the ballot paper
but until that time I think what we
don't want a more unicorns more
fantasies we want something that's
specific and deliverable just finally
the papers today a full of rumors about
coos against Theresa May 3 named in the
frame for caretaker leader reportedly
David Ludington Jeremy Hunt and I have
Jeremy Hunt David Livington I'm doing
that you did know I could go that's a
must meet me and you need enough copy
this apologies to Michael Gove if you're
watching just the thought of having a
new leader of the Conservative Party
fool you with optimism or alarm if it
fills me with horror to be honest you
know we're in this whole mess because
the whole referendum process grew out of
a massive row in the Conservative Party
and David Cameron trying to keep onboard
those MPs would otherwise go and join
you Kip and yet again we're having
another fight within the Conservative
Party at the time when we're facing the
greatest constitutional crisis this
country has faced since the Second World
War I think it is massively reckless and
self-indulgent of them I'm no fan of
mrs. May I think she's almost uniquely
incompetent at the job she's been given
to do but the problem are the
contradictions within the brexit
proposal itself this idea about how you
get the hard brexit and you also manage
to somehow not have a hard border in
northern ireland that is at the center
of this it's not origins of mrs. May do
feel sort of personal level
you bet I feel sorry for I wouldn't be
her for a lot of money Caroline Lucas
thank you very much thank you